we're here with the beautiful and
talented Jessica Biel who I was just
girls talking with in the break and
before the break we asked Jessica
um which play she was a part of as a kid
Cinderella or Annie Jessica what is the
right answer Annie oh I was gonna say
please say Annie oh hey this is my
my dream had come true what role were
you Annie yeah of course you were Annie
of course and I said you could have worn
the Wiggy war and candy yeah one of the
best performances of the year and very
well accoladed all right we're gonna
keep playing the game I don't know any
of the answers Ross take it away I'm
very excited okay well here's how the
game works I really want to get this
right yeah I want you to get it right
too I'm going to take you through three
stations and each station has two items
one item tells a true story about
Jessica and the other is fake whichever
you think is true you'll say is the real
deal got it okay and then Jessica after
Drew guesses
you will reveal which is correct okay
and if Drew gets any of them wrong
you're gonna have to do this workout
Challenge from Jessica's Instagram
that's Jessica by the way I I
corroborate this is what they look like
in the gym like nerdy but it's so hard
oh my god oh this is embarrassing Bear's
stuff no it's cute you guys are fit and
like ready to go I know you know what
you're not what any relationship I've
ever looked like looks like well if you
get them wrong I'll do the workout with
you all right so it will look like that
all right so let's get started first up
uh which is an item that Jessica loves
to collect does she collect do not
disturb signs from hotels around the
country or does she collect vintage
glasses without the lenses I have a very
strong sense that it is the Do Not
Disturb okay let's lock in on do not
disturb signs uh Jessica is Drew correct
[Applause]
all right next up which item did Jessica
and her brother try to sell to all the
neighborhood kids was it rocks covered
in glitter that they claimed from outer
space
or was it Spa water AKA bathtub water
mixed with a variety of shampoos and
soaps Drew which one is the real deal
I'm gonna go with Spa water okay uh
Jessica is she correct correct
she got one
you were selling Spa water to neighbors
we called it Spa water it was I'm in the
bathtub with my brother pouring soap and
shampoo and conditioner and we're
scooping it into bottles and going
around the neighborhood with a wagon
at an early age I'm impressed thank you
well you made some cash
all right last up walk down here if you
will we want to know Drew how did
Jessica decorate her Christmas tree as a
kid did she use detached Barbie doll
heads or did she use creepy sock puppets
I'm gonna go with dolls I really hope
you're right because that's so weird I
really hope it's right Jessica Biel yes
yes
[Applause]
look how look how cool they look with
the lights coming through I don't tell
you it just tried it one year and I was
like this is the new thing my mother was
like okay I think you're a genius
brilliant and look how Barbie she's so
thrilled she's glowing she's just so
happy
but drew that we we did get one wrong
and you know what that means work out
time to hit the floor how do we do that
okay okay
okay all we have to do is get in a plank
okay and then we're just gonna go like
this
with our arms okay it's just a poor
shoulder workout we can really do this
okay okay okay go we got this you guys
ready yes right left bend them back oh
left back
[Applause]
I can do it we're doing it
Nationwide
you're so strong
[Music]